[Music]
NASA this morning will outline its very
first mission directly into the sun's
atmosphere the Solar Probe plus is
scheduled to launch in the summer of
2018 it will orbit within 4 million
miles of the Sun surface now that's
about seven times closer than the Helios
spacecraft got in 1976 at its closest
approach the probe will hurtle around
the Sun at about 450,000 miles an hour
that speed is fast enough to travel from
Philadelphia to DC in one second CBS
News science and futuristic contributor
that's Michio Kaku is a physics
professor at the city university of new
york city and joins us at the table
good to see you professor glad to be
here we're glad you're here how big a
deal is this and what is NASA hoping to
learn well first of all this is
embarrassing we're 50 years into the
Space Age we visited the planets we
visited comets and asteroids but we've
never had a close encounter with the Sun
why which is the most important object
in the solar system now we've been
looking for life in Mars and that's why
we went to the moons of Jupiter and
Saturn looking for evidence of of life
and maybe oceans out there so we
neglected the Sun but the Sun controls
space whether the solar winds which can
damage our satellites injure astronauts
even endanger a mission to Mars wipe out
power plants on the planet Earth that's
why it's important that we understand
the solar wind but following up on
Gail's question why have we not done
this well first of all it is difficult
we have to be in a very precise orbit
skimming skimming the surface of the Sun
by four million miles that means we're
going to whip around Venus we're going
to rip around Venus several times to get
right in position so that we can make a
close encounter with the Sun and the
heat shields have to have to withstand
temperatures at 2,500 2,600 degrees
Fahrenheit yeah sometimes it's hard to
get close to something that's very hot
that's what I was thinking it's Joe I
don't know what their yeah are they
going to do that yes well they have
carbon composites on a heat shield very
specially crafted so that it can
withstand these incredible blisteringly
hot temperatures because we're going to
get right through the corona of the Sun
now that's important because that's
where the coronal mass ejections are
born these are gigantic solar flares
like bullets will one day perhaps hit
the earth in 2012 we just missed one and
that big one could have wiped out
communications on the planet Earth if it
had hit in 2012 how long is all of this
going to take do you think the whole
mission is six years it's going to go
around Venus several times and then whip
around the Sun several times so the the
mission will last for about six years
okay boys and girls who are watching
this we'll have a test at the end
program has been prepared very much okay
Michio Kaku always great to have you
here thank you so much